عيد ميلاد افتراضي على غرار عيد الميلاد
اثناء الوباء هو التوصيف الانسب للحاله
التي ستمر بها بريطانيا خلال عطله الاعياد
القادمه
قطارات لن تدور على السكك لايام لتتوقف
اهم سبل النقل التي تعتمد عليها المملكه
40 الف عامل في القطاع واربعه عشر الف مش
شغال او 14 مشغل قطارات مضربون عن العمل
بدءا من اليوم وحتى السبت المقبل رساله
مفادها بكل اختصار نريد شروط افضل للعمل
واجور اعلى والا ستستمر الاضطرابات حتى
يناير المقبل ايضا اما السيناريو الاسوء
والاسباب ذاتها فيجري في المشافي التي
اوقفت استقبال المرضى فلا ممرضات في
الخدمه 100,000 ممرضه في 76 مشفى ومؤسسات
تابعه لخدمات الصحه الوطنيه اضربنا عن
العمل وذلك لاول مره منذ اكثر من قرن
مطالبات بزياده الاجور بنسبه قعدت 10%
قبلت بالرفض من قبل رئيس الوزراء الجديد
ريشي سوناك قائلا انها غير معقوله فيما
ينتظر
400,000 مريض في بريطانيا دورهم لاجراء
عمليات جراحيه سيعاد جدوالتها وتاجيل 1500
منها بدءا من الاول ومن الاول وال 21 من
ديسمبر وحتى اشعار اخر تعطي العام لا عطله
ميلاد فحسب ستجبر المواطنين على التزام
منازلهم لتواجه حكومه سوناك احد اصعب
تحدياتها